come on man I know you watching man is
still where's the review act okay I'll
just go to Wayne tube calm oh um we're
Stefan's Manistee with you refresh
refresh refresh months Stockman where's
your man steal review
for those who are watching this video
who are not subscribed to me you should
know that this will be a spoiler free
review I do not do spoilers in my
reviews you're safe with me don't worry
I will however do a spoiler filled
review this weekend to look forward to
that Man of Steel is directed by Zack
Snyder it stars Henry Cavill Michael
Shannon Amy Adams Laurence Fishburne
Kevin Costner Russell Crowe amazing cast
in this movie and if you don't know this
is a reboot and a retelling of the
origin story of kal-el or Superman
produced by Christopher Nolan the man
behind the Dark Knight films this film
had a lot going for it and I was so
excited to see this movie because I'm
always been a fan of Superman my entire
life and since this movie also has the
hopes and dreams of the Justice League
on his shoulders there's a lot of things
riding on this movie this movie opens
with a grand vision of Krypton you see
the much known story of how Superman
came to earth and how that all started
but you've never seen it like this
before you actually get a look outside
you get a look at some of the creatures
that live on Krypton you get a look at
Kryptonian technology and I love the way
this film opened it was really intense
it was a lot of fun really good action
in there and I really loved Russell
Crowe as jor-el he did such a terrific
job in this movie and I honestly think
he's one of the best parts of this movie
actually when we do get to earth we see
an adult Superman and we learn more
about him through flashbacks and
backstory we get to meet Jonathan Kent
through these flashbacks played by Kevin
Costner terrific job in the film as well
one of his best performances he's done
in years he was so good as POC and he
really honestly was great in this movie
and the movie did a fair job of giving
you a good look at Superman's childhood
and you got a good sense of how that was
despite the fact that some of it was a
little cliched with the bullies always
saying hey fight back Kent what you're
not going to fight like it was just kind
of like the cliched bully picks on the
little kid thing soon enough we do meet
Lois Lane's character we're introduced
to certain people at the Daily Planet we
get to see Superman in his suit and now
General Zod has a warning for Superman
he's coming to earth and stuffs about to
go down between Superman and Zod and
it's pretty epic so how is Man of Steel
overall I think it's a very good
superhero film I don't think it's quite
as good as it could have been though I
do think that it could have been
slightly better and I'll explain why
nevertheless Man of Steel seriously does
rock at points there's a lot of great
sequences in this movie and finally we
were able to
get a look at a Superman that can
actually kick some serious Kryptonian
ass fight scenes in this movie fantastic
thank goodness we finally got that
because when's the last time we saw
Superman actually fight somebody
Superman for the quest for peace yeah
this film has a ton of action and
although you can tell that it's CGI just
because your eyes are trained that way
there is a little bit overuse of it but
there were some scenes where they
actually transitioned extremely smoothly
from a CGI Superman right into the real
Henry Cavill and they did a really good
job with that it was very seamless and I
was pretty impressed with it henry
cavill is good as Superman I think that
he's probably the best Superman we've
had since read I really don't think
anyone is ever going to be able to step
into christopher reeve shoes he did such
an iconic job in those movies but henry
cavill did do a good job in this film
and i'm excited to see where else he
takes the character how was Michael
Shannon as Zod I think he did fine he
did a good job but to say that he did
fine is a little disappointing because
he's such a good actor I think that he
did a terrific job for the material he
was given but he didn't really have that
driving home force that Heath Ledger as
the Joker did or Tom Hiddleston as Loki
did it just wasn't at that level of
menace and that was something that was
disappointing to me however there is
something I did really like about his
villain you understood where he was
coming from he wasn't just a mindless
guy who just wanted to hurt people
he actually had a plan and you got it
and those are what some of the best
villains are in a movie is when you can
understand where they're coming from and
you understand why they are the way they
are I like that about General Zod this
movie and as I said Michael Shannon did
do a good job I just don't think the
material he was given was as strong as
it should have been also Hans Zimmer
score fantastic following the footsteps
of John Williams and not a fun thing I'm
sure the score was enthralling and it
touched me at times it gave me
goosebumps I really enjoyed it
Amy Adams is Lois Lane did a pretty good
job in this movie Laurence Fishburne as
Perry White also did a good job I really
don't feel like these actors were given
the right material to be able to really
shine in these roles and there are a few
lines that come off as very cheesy
specifically any of the military
dialogue like they'd be looking at a big
hi-tech screening or like based off
these readings that means this is going
to happen don't dun dunnn just a little
cheesy at times but I can forgive that
but okay let me get to my main issue I
had with this movie and that is the fact
that the film's structure isn't really a
solid as I would like it to
the film goes from huge scene to huge
scene to big gigantic scene and it
really doesn't feel like you get that
time to cool down from it and what I
mean by that is some of the scenes they
cracked are so cool and really fun and
exciting but the needed human element
and the emotion behind the character of
Superman I kind of felt was a little bit
lacking his character really wasn't
given as much depth as I thought he was
going to be as I look back on the movie
and I envision certain scenes I always
like wow that was a really well-done
scene and everything and everyone was
doing a really good job in the scene but
it wasn't constructed as well as it
could have been it was a lot of really
awesome scenes strung together really
fast and sometimes they didn't have the
needed weight that I was hoping for the
needed character the needed depth that I
wanted nevertheless Man of Steel is
still a very fun summer action film it's
the best Superman film I'd say we've
gotten since the first one from 1978
Henry Cavill is good as Superman the
score is good it's great to see Superman
finally throw down with someone I'm
going to give Man of Steel a b-plus when
you guys do see the movie or if you have
already let me know what you think below
and always thanks for watching guys I
really appreciate it also I want to say
special thanks to my fellow YouTube
buddies who helped me with my skit in
the beginning Jon Flickinger of the
flick pick Erik Stifler of pretty much
it and Victor the frickin film critic
links for other channels are in the
description below and I hope you check
them out because they are all worth your
time and if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes